what's up Steven good to see you again
nice to see you um I'm going to start
with congrats on season three I watched
the whole thing uh thank you for making
me laugh
oh good yeah what'd you think
uh I'm gonna give it a thumbs up and I'm
ready for season four that's what I got
see you later
um so I have to I guess I'll start with
the most important question first do you
find that when rexim is doing better Rob
is in a better mood
it definitely doesn't hurt uh
but uh but yeah he's uh he's he's got uh
many interests and uh rexham being one
of them but I never know how they're
doing is the thing you know I I can't
watch the game so
um but as long as the wrexham show is
doing well then uh I mean that's that's
better than anything when we spoke at
Comic-Con Megan mentioned that she knows
the very end of the series like what
it's gonna be
um has she has she told you what that is
uh no she hasn't and did she tell you if
she told you you can tell me no you know
what's funny I would love to I actually
don't want to know what the end is
because I'm a fan and I want to get
there naturally but I am curious who
she's told
uh yeah I think she's told her dog
exactly she has she really tells that
dog everything and uh uh maybe I'll ask
the dog
uh I am curious what what have you what
are you allowed or what do you want to
tell people about season three and the
adventure that is coming season three is
louder it's faster it's funnier uh no I
a season three I um season three is fun
for us because I think we'll be fun for
the audience because
um we have a completely new uh look to
Mythic Quest we have a whole new uh eye
and a poppy have broken off and uh and
they have a whole new office and company
that they're running uh we get to see
David uh you know alone and how he is
thriving uh running Mythic Quest on his
own
um with some new opportunities we get to
see Joe Manganiello uh interact with uh
David's pursuing the uh uh star and uh
trying to quote unquote bag of Beefcake
with Joe Manganiello for his uh Mythic
Quest movie and we get we just get to
see there's more Carol
um who's who's so funny Naomi perigine
and uh uh more uh more of our characters
evolving and in new situations which uh
you know evolving their careers in
different ways including Brad being a
janitor so there's a lot of new looks
um not just on the set but with our
characters that I think people will find
exciting so you guys were picked up for
season three and season four uh together
and I'm curious what was that like the
behind the scenes in developing The Arc
the storyline this season how much are
you thinking about you know what are we
going to do in both seasons and how much
is sort of like let's just write three
we get to the end and then we'll worry
about four I think it's more the latter
I think you have to serve the story in
in the present you know everyone's
always trying to live in the present
right well it's the same thing I think
with writing you know you uh you plan
ahead as far as you can but you you know
that you could end up throwing stuff out
you know as you because as you write and
as you you know keep packing your way
through the season things change you
know you start to take a different path
than you thought you were going to take
and so there's only so much planning you
can do
um it's it's hard enough to plan 10
episodes I think we have a few maybe
tent poles along the way that we have
ideas for but I think with anything you
have to know you might let those go
because you'll hopefully find something
even more interesting pardon me for not
knowing but have you filmed season four
are you getting ready to see film season
four what's the status uh no we have not
even met for season four and started the
room yet
um we've got Always Sunny to do and then
we'll be back with season four and so um
so there's a little bit of um there's a
little bit hang time between between
Seasons yeah I'm not a fan of that I
need that I know quicker
um I'm joking around obviously but you
got you know tell Rob to have less shows
you know exactly uh you directed episode
seven which is the first Christmas
episode of Mythic Quest if I'm not
mistaken
um can you sort of talk about did you
get to pick that episode or was that the
one that sort of fell in your lap
um no I you know I picked I wanted to
direct the season and um I I picked the
Christmas episode because it it felt
special to me you know I worked a lot on
the script and the story and uh in
particular and I I'm in a lot of it
which even though it makes for a more
challenging directing experience I
wanted
um to have more control over it as well
as it feeling special because it's a
Christmas episode you know hopefully
um it's a bit more emotional uh while
still keeping you know still having a
lot of fun it's uh it feels a little
extra special we have some extra
um special moments in there and uh I
just I wanted to have uh a little bit
more
um involvement
um by directing it one of the things I
found interesting about the Ian poppy
relationship this season is that Ian
actually feels like he's grown since
over the since the first two seasons
like he's actually caring about what
other people think well Poppy and can
you sort of talk about they haven't
really they've left Mythic Quest but
they haven't really left
well you never really leave right in a
sense uh
um well they can't you know you can take
the you can you know take the person out
of mythical but you can't take mythicus
out of the person I think is what we'll
find
um uh I think iron is constantly
trying to evolve uh because in a sense
uh you know just like the metaverse he
knows things are evolving and uh but he
also struggles with you know his own
nature
um which I think we all do as we try to
you know grow as people and so um so I I
think that was that's sort of the fun of
his character and of the partnership you
know we really try to dive deep and and
take that that a very minimal set that
they have which is sort of an embodiment
of ion's mind it's his design and put
our two main characters in there and
really see how they interact and how
they struggle and that was uh kind of a
highlight for the season for us to to
try to keep diving deep Even in our
Breakaway episode we we dive deep there
of the three seasons which shot or
sequence ended up being the toughest to
pull off uh and why
gosh anything with a lot of extras
it's always tricky uh you know we
usually do these E3
um like we had a episode in season two
that we ended up cutting but it built to
us premiering at E3
um and uh I was just thinking that we
have all these you know these episodes
where you bring in a whole crowd right
and you really uh those are uh those
become more of a just a from a
production side uh bigger um but what's
funny now is that you know
I mean I don't know the state of e3 at
this moment but we're you know we've
turned we looked at that season I mean
that episode in season three and said
well E3 you know that doesn't that feels
like Gathering everyone in this room is
is not really uh what we're doing these
days so uh we ended up leaning away from
that so honestly the pandemic in itself
has been the most challenging way to
where we adjusted but from that I think
we ended up coming up with
um better material and even our
specifically our um our quarantine
episode
um that was probably the biggest
challenge that we then had to deal with
I just want to thank you again for
making a show that I really really love
um and have a fantastic day oh thank you
sir appreciate it